and then apocalypse now is my favorite
war film okay
so what's the apocalypse what is it even
about apocalypse now is based on the
vietnam war
yeah that's all i know about it with
like basically the uh
it's it's told from the american side
where like american troops
are told so uh martin sheen is the main
character
um and he is like set on a mission to go
and pick up
a soldier from like he's like he's like
a vet
who's the director francis ford coppola
it's the same person who made godfather
oh yeah so france thought koppler like
this is like one of his most famous
films i think did you know francis ford
coppola is actually the uncle to
nicholas cage
random facts i found out at the end of
the day okay but so basically it's said
where like martin sheen's character's
team has to go into the vietnam forest
to go and look for
this like vet who holds a lot of
information about the vietnam war yeah
basically he's kind of gone
insane and is living in the vietnam
language because it's marlon brando it's
marlon brando
basically it's it's uh yeah so marlon
brando's character is this like
viet like soldier vet who like holds a
lot of information and like he needs to
be
brought back to the us army basically
martin sheen's character goes in
tries to fight off all the the viet cong
and you know tries to get him back
basically but as manchin's character is
going through all of these like life and
death situations stuff like that
he too also slowly starts to lose his
mind
and then eventually and then you know
that poster there's pretty much
[ __ ] awesome poster yeah pretty much
sums up like that scene where he like
comes out of the pool as there's like
fighting happening is one of the coolest
[ __ ] scenes in cinema
that sounds cool marlon brando is like
fantastic is it a thinking movie
i don't know what do i have to think
during this movie well okay so
apocalypse now
has like a a director's cut called
apocalypse now redux which is like three
and a half hours long
because how long is the original three
hours oh yeah so it's all along okay
okay because
here's the thing about apocalypse now
because everything you described i
already kind of knew about it because i
knew like the basic
plot description and everything like
that yeah what makes it good
okay so in my opinion one makes it
really good is just the fact well
first of all it's like the music choice
in that movie is [ __ ] brilliant it's
like
everything i [ __ ] love like in my
opinion apocalypse now still has one of
the greatest openings i've seen like
any movie very iconic yeah um but i
don't know it's also just like again
it's like it takes that like kind of
war element and weirdly enough it's a
vietnam war film
that doesn't really have a whole lot of
fighting yeah like really the most
amount of like
fighting between the us army and vietnam
really happens in like the first like
maybe 20 minutes right and then the rest
of the movie is literally just
you're inside the mind of manchin's
character as he's like
slowly venturing closer and closer to
his target and he's
slowly like losing his mind as a result
of war and it's like a very like
i don't know it's like a really weird
like psychological twist
on a war movie that you don't really
like because when you think of war movie
right you think of like
saving private ryan whereas like yeah
there's obviously a lot of like you know
soldiers getting [ __ ] up in the war
scenes right but like there's also a lot
of like
fighting scenes happening right like
gunfighting scenes or whatever the [ __ ]
it is
whereas apocalypse now doesn't really
have a whole lot of that it's like it's
almost like a psychological horror set
during the vietnam war okay and i think
that's what personally that's what makes
it really interesting to me yeah because
it's cool because the thing is i think i
know
more about apocalypse now than the
actual
than actually seeing the movie itself
yeah yeah because i i know like
i think this has like a really
interesting story behind how it was made
yeah uh because like i i think uh
the director himself i think almost went
bankrupt making this movie
or something like that yeah uh because
he had to like convince
the studio that he owned or something to
like lend him the money
to make this movie and he was out there
for like months and months shooting this
movie
it almost wasn't made and i think like
marlon brando just
refused to read the script yeah refused
to remember his lines
yeah yeah he's been notorious for that
though yeah he hasn't here but
this was the first movie where he
started to become like this and then the
godfather i think happened
after apocalypse now which like then or
was it the other way around i think it
was the other way
it might have been the other way around
yeah basically yeah marlon brando
doesn't appear in this movie
until maybe about two and a half hours
yeah i i think like most of his lines
are just
like ad-libbed because he just refused
to
remember his line so i'm just like how
does that work how does that look like
i've ever seen
any of the movies that he's in but i
know that he's like notorious for being
awful to work with yeah yeah yeah
i mean you know like during his prime
obviously it was a fantastic and you
know he's still a fantastic actor in
this movie as well but it's like
it's very clear that he's not like at
his peak but i feel like
martin sheen's performance in this movie
is just so goddamn good yeah that like
he does such an amazing job of like
really like progressively showing
someone going inside yeah yeah yeah
i don't know it's funny my opinion is
fantastic i remember i think it was on
joe rogan i think um
no no no um robert downey jr was talking
about
sometimes he didn't remember lines yeah
i think when he did
which i think sherlock he remembered all
his lines for but other movies he was
just like just put put an earpiece in
just feeding their lives
well honestly like especially when he's
like iron man he's just acting robert
downey jr
he was saying you know some films don't
require me to get that deep into the
character so there's
no point in spending all this time
learning the lines but like i think for
like sherlock it was like quite
difficult
some of the lines in the way that he was
doing it so he wanted to learn it yeah
he's just like yeah it depends on the
movie but the way he's he made it sound
but it seemed like oh that makes sense
then when you hear about like the third
party accounts of marlon brando
this sounds like [ __ ] hell yeah right
and i bet like you know because there's
a lot of big actors in this name like um
harrison ford's in this movie as well
yeah just before he's angry at
everything
this is before he's angry yeah but like
i don't know just really really good
movie in my opinion